this is not your first rodeo there's you
with Broadway Joe look at that hey all
right let his gaze upon the magnificence
of that picture and let me ask you a
question which is why our America's
companies trying to make me feel bad as
a dad I think America's companies are
doing a great job idealizing the
american dad and actually the american
family loved it or hated and there have
been mixed reviews the McDonald's
commercial did a tremendous job really
touching the heartstrings of American
moms well so the McDonald's commercial
plate up this idea of you can pay with
love and you can call your mom and tell
her that you love her and then you can
get a very big jack are you gonna do you
think it's a smart strategy for
McDonald's to be rolling out a campaign
that has nothing to do with its product
I think it's probably smart strategy to
do that McDonald is product a little to
be doing so well right little bit of
don't look here look here yeah critical
in your world I didn't get the mcdonalds
at I didn't get the nationwide and on
and on yeah and then I totally got the
one you love he always add I totally got
puppy and budweiser how do bad ads get
made bad ads get made because frequently
in corporate America people do not like
to say to their boss or to their client
this isn't a good idea well here's the
good idea d tree as Brendan check this
out this is out on Twitter afterwards
this is a kid from the loser nationwide
ad on katy perry iphone much katy perry
because i died in a depressing that was
great I've had to say but this idea of
you know about d lysing the american dad
let's let's play that nissan nascar
driving at because that one made me
really angry so basically there's a guy
he's a NASCAR driver totally you know he
goes through an entire lifetime of
ignoring his son he finally wins the cup
and somehow it's okay that he's been a
bad bad because he drives a nice it's
okay be that he's been an absent father
just cuz it's teenage son got picked up
and does this like tough get made well I
think the bigger question is some of the
commercials you see from first-time
advertisers I thought wicks did an
incredible job with wix wix.com they are
they very topical yeah they used not
just ex-nfl players but ex-nfl players
who had epic superbowl performances
across the board I
overall it did feel like a very somber
set of commercials is pulling on
heartstrings more effective than humor
humor usually works but if it's bad
humor that can be a total disaster
pulling on heartstrings dogs horses
generally win kids people who are
disabled / challenge etc again tugged on
people's heart strings I mean I thought
that for me the commercial that stood
out not because it was a great
commercial because there was a great
story behind it was this go daddy yet
again this amazing jujitsu move where
they accidentally released this
completely tasteless ad and we're dad
and then they go to their actual ad
puppy I know for the active truck the
actual ad they ran last night was just a
guy sitting at a computer working really
hard it was not godaddy at all it had
nothing to do with all their weird sort
of sexy awkward ads that they've done in
the past was just a dude making making
things work well I think the other
commercial that they had planned wasn't
going to make it on air and they just
went in the other direction and
surprised the American consumer in the
advertising community in your experience
who green lights garbage ads does a CEO
of a company go no this is the yet I
want and override the advertising people
or just some 24 year old kid from
Brooklyn that doesn't get how America
thinks right ray I need to jump in here
he's serious because he has his glasses
off so you better answer the question
yeah I'm serious I look creatives so to
speak take over the day frequently and
really it all comes down to an idea and
an idea that resonates against the
target audience and it's not always
about production values and production
expense did you see anything new in the
ads did you see anything that you
thought huh I haven't seen that before
that works you know it's funny but I
really thought that going back to wix
com and I have no prior relationship
with that company but I thought they
that just blocking and tackling so speak
well I like this Kim Kardashian one for
tmobile I miss this sort of a PSA yeah
she pretends I missed this 22 as well
the tone was as if it was you know a
charity advert but instead it was a just
just a spoof on needing more data plans
you know we're all doing the water
cooler conversation right now but what
what do you look for what are the
metrics you look for the night of and
the next day to actually show
empirically what worked I looked at
nfl.com I wanted to see what people that
were on nfl.com we're voting as well as
the couple of hundred people that are in
the USA Today theatre hmm at the end of
the day the most important thing is if
you were to do proper research and
understand if you were able to impact
brand kpi's brand metrics in the way you
want to do are you the brand that is
most closely associated with the NFL etc
brand spent four and a half million
dollars in advertising and not enough on
research pre during and post on Ricky
thank you so much with Columbia
University